quel est votre plan de voler tout ça
illégal de ce contrôle je vous présente
ma pièce d'identité vous avez lu vous
savez lire monsieur voilà vous savez mon
identité le contrôle terminé en début de
son caractère illégal merci beaucoup
monsieur au revoir vous êtes sur une
piste monsieur avez-vous une
habilitation pour attirer une piste qui
sont du parquet pour arrêter la viande
alors vous allez récupérer
de te faire arrêter de
la peur c'est une émotion moi je
commence un plan un plan qui doit
redonner l'espoir au peuple je peux plus
écouter mes émotions c'est quoi ton but
tu veux te présenter tu veux faire quoi
non moi j'ai un rêve hein c'est que la
France redevienne une démocratie oui
c'est une dictature et que les Français
retrouvent leur
dignités
comme un citoyen vous avez été vous avez
été arrêté vous avez passé combien de
jours j'ai vécu les trois dernières
semaines du régime irakien sous Saddam
Hussein raisonné j'ai donné à Cyril
Hanouna hein
parce que j'étais assis pas ça une
dictature monsieur merci c'est pas ça
vous connaissez pas
je suis arrivé en Irak j'ai travaillé
avec des gens qui avaient 30 ans non non
mais voilà je suis en train de vous
expliquer très subtil non non c'est pas
abusés dans leur foyer et je pense que
ceux qui ont perdu un œil de les gilets
jaunes qui ont perdu un œil dont vous
parlez de les jeunes qui ont perdu un
œil c'est normal ça Mounir
alors
en fait je comprends pas ce que vous
voulez bah voilà parce que votre
banderole moi j'aimerais bien la
banderole mais avec aller voter la
prochaine fois parce qu'en fait il a été
élu Macron démocratiquement c'est pas
important ce que je veux moi mais c'est
important on l'a entendu dans les dans
les sifflets du Stade de France on l'a
encore entendu
[Musique]
l'important c'est de poser la question
au peuple encore une fois c'est pas
l'importance que moi je désire mais si
vous voulez vous désirez quelque chose
vous allez vous faire part de vos désirs
maintenant moi je suis pas là pour faire
part de mes désirs je suis là pour
rappeler aux Français leurs dignité de
peuple souverains le boss c'est le
peuple l'employé c'est Macron mais si le
beurre si le peuple choisi de garder son
employé là moi je m'en fiche
à chaque jour ici il y a une nouvelle
faute grave l'employé il part c'est une
question parce que vous dites je viens
pour délivrer un message mais vous savez
que le message il arrive pas exnil c'est
celui qui le délivre aussi qui est
important qui êtes-vous qui qui est-ce
que vous avez des ambitions politiques
est-ce que vous soutenez un parti
politique vous n'êtes pas obligé
montrez-moi une carte politique que
j'aurais auquel je reste
à aucun mouvement politique j'ai adhéré
à aucun moment
politique et ce que je regrette c'est
qu'il y ait des gens qui meurent ou qui
se prennent une balle dans l'oeil et
quand vous me parlez de peur que moi
j'ai eu peur j'ai eu peur parce qu'après
tous les coups de matraque sous Macron
quand j'ai vu que tout d'un coup la
répression c'était pas juste se faire
tabasser parce que je me suis fait
tabasser une bonne vingtaine de fois et
on a les images et bah quand j'ai vu que
la répression ensuite c'était carrément
perdre un œil ou perdre une main et ben
je suis resté à l'étranger ouais et j'ai
eu honte et j'ai eu honte parce que vous
auriez pu porter
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît monsieur
le juge rendez-moi mon œil
parce que vous êtes proche de la lsfi ou
pas du tout moi j'ai envie d'être proche
de tout le monde c'est un peu mon
ambition en tant que chrétien c'est ce
qu'on dit et j'ai contacté
[Musique]
à Alexis Poulin j'essaie de contacter à
peu près tout le monde si un jour moi
j'ai envie de parler à tout le monde à
Mélenchon je pense que tout le monde on
peut se mettre d'accord pour redonner
leur sens à l'article 1 de la
Constitution la République est
démocratique et la République elle est
démocratique de la Constitution un
gouvernement du peuple pour le peuple et
par le peuple David où c'est que c'est
le gouvernement c'est de Macron pour
Macron et pour les milliardaires vous
êtes trop jeune pour savoir ça non mais
David vous voulez faire quoi vous faites
c'est quoi non mais vous voulez devenir
Président vous voulez faire quoi non
j'ai pas d'ambition
alors j'ai lancé une pétition au
non non on a proposé aux gens de la
rejoindre le mouvement et il suffit
simplement de dire je veux la
destitution de Macron en application de
l'article 68 de la Constitution si
écoutez le plan est tout simple il y a
combien de personnes on s'organise il y
a un plan là on en a la phase
d'organisation vous êtes 500 deuxième
partie du plan deuxième partie du plan
on pourra s'adresser à l'ensemble des
Français et leur demander voilà est-ce
que vous êtes 10 millions à vouloir au
départ de Macron est-ce que vous êtes 30
millions est-ce que vous êtes 60
millions c'est ça la bonne question
aujourd'hui vous voulez me s’enchaîner
mais moi je suis un nobody moi si vous
m'envoyez en prison mais j'en ai rien à
faire la vraie question c'est ce que les
Français ont envie d'envoyer Macron en
prison
il y a l'article 68 de la Constitution
qui rappelle qu'en cas de faute lourdes
de cette employé le poste au travers de
ces représentants ont le droit de virer
va falloir que vous voulez est-ce que
vous avez une étiquette politique
écoutez moi j'ai une seule étiquette là
c'est celle du peuple
et les filles non je suis juste un
citoyen et j'ai lu la Constitution
pour qui vous avez voté au premier pas
très important
c'est pas très important
voilà j'ai voté le vote est dormi secret
a priori je croyais la dernière nouvelle
les secrets non mais tu as le droit de
dire vraiment la vie tu as le droit de
pas le dire voilà mais eux ils dormaient
Montier Raymond là ils étaient en train
de dormir qu'est-ce qu'il veut non mais
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que derrière
cette façade de provocateur vous avez
une idéologie et c'est idéologie c'est
contre le mariage
mais oui mais d'accord
je suis pas sûr tous les Français le
savent monsieur que vous êtes contre le
mariage pour tous on est d'accord
écoutez moi les lois c'est important
c'est qu'elle soit prise de manière
démocratique
moi je suis désolé pardon je vais vous
parler ouvertement vous me faites peur
c'est j'ai peur moi de ce type de
comportement moi j'ai peur là votre
comportement sur le plateau j'ai peur je
suis désolé on est en démocratie
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire mais à
aucun moment qu'on n'est pas en
démocratie j'entends tous les points de
vie j'entends tous les points de vue
mais vous me faites peur vous avez
personne dans votre vie combien de
personnes tabasser vous avez vu parce
que dans votre famille vous voyez des
gens se faire tabasser non et bah si
vous allez dans la rue avec la
démocratie parce que votre croyance
qu'on est en démocratie c'est que vous
avez jamais vu des gens qui
manifestaient pacifiquement alors assis
tranquillement se faire saisir par des
flics tabasser arrêtez et ça se passe en
France et j'ai donné les images à Cyril
et s'il veut les montrer il peut les
montrer c'est quoi les images bah montre
les images alors vous vous parlez
d'employés
[Applaudissements]
toujours comme ça donc dites-moi s'ils
les ont pas merci elles sont censurées
sur partout parce que effectivement on
n'a pas le droit de dire que la France
c'est une dictature et du coup tous les
images sur tous les réseaux sociaux les
tabassages du militant Pacifique c'est
un appareil nulle part nulle part
on est en dictature ok on est sûr
d'accord vous êtes quand même sur
d'ailleurs visiblement c'est quand même
une dictature plutôt cool mais on est en
dictature donc dans 4 ans il y a des
prochaines élections est-ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre une élection avec au
suffrage universel ce que vous voulez un
président vous les personnes ce que vous
l'avez faites les autres présidents
à un empereur japonais ils prennent un
empereur japonais c'est le peuple le
boss c'est le peuple moi mon opinion
c'est une parmi 30 millions oui mais
vous dites que vous êtes là pour
délivrer un message donc vous êtes bien
là on porte drapeau de quelque chose que
je délivre c'est la Constitution article
68 ça a du mal à rentrer parce
qu'effectivement personne ne connaît
vous le connaissez l'article 68 bah vous
venez nous le dire donc oui je le
connais maintenant vous avez de la
chance
vous avez en parler le prof de maths et
de danse vous voulez pas retourner là
dedans arrêtez de faire chier
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu voudrais toi voilà toi
voilà qu'est-ce que tu veux tu voudrais
quoi parce que
une France
ou tous les abstentionnistes se disent
ah ouais moi je crois dans le système
maintenant mon bulletin de vote il sert
à quelque chose je vais aller le mettre
donc vous croyez pas aussi thème en fait
vous êtes plus pour le suffrage
universel non moi je suis pour le
suffrage universel mais suffrage
universel qui soit pas une illusion vous
croyez que encore une fois je vais
répéter tout à l'heure si vous êtes
marié à quelqu'un et qu'à chaque fois
qu'il se prononce pas vous dites elle
dit oui je fais tout ce que je veux
c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment
Macron il croit qu'il a un chèque en
blanc alors que il y a 80 % de Français
qui sont pas satisfaits après l'élection
juste après l'élection contre les votes
blancs et les abstentions c'est ça
l'esprit de la Cinquième République
en vrai on a une monarchie avec une
personne qui prend toutes les décisions
d'ailleurs vous savez on peut aller plus
loin que le mot monarchie parce qu'il y
a un auteur célèbre qui a dit la
dictature c'est quand un homme ou un
clan prend les lois tout seul vous savez
qui a dit ça
c'est Macron
et moi je pense que avec le nombre de
49,3 qui prend on a on a Macron qui dit
lui-même en ce moment mon équipe est en
train de les mettre sur les réseaux
sociaux Macron bien sûr ça coûte cher un
avion qui c'est qui qui paye quand j'ai
commencé j'avais rien j'ai plutôt des
dettes et puis je suis parti avec zéro
euro
et puis au bout d'une semaine je me suis
dit peut-être qu'il faudrait que je
finance et on a lancé une cagnotte
aujourd'hui il y a 25000 euros sur la
cagnotte parce que elle est tonnes de
Français qui veulent le soutenir et je
pense qu'il aurait bien plus une fois
que les Français réalisent que c'est
tout à fait démocratique de demander la
discussion d'un Président
c'est vrai ou pas j'ai refusé de venir
il y a cinq jours parce parce que c'est
la première réunion de mon équipe je les
connaissais pas enfin je les ai
rencontré au fur et à mesure sur les
plages j'ai vu que les gens ils étaient
enthousiasme et ben on a monté une
équipe c'est de phase 1 et
l'organisation on vient de commencer la
phase 2 bah la phase 2 c'est quand on
est bien organisé on va pouvoir
s'adresser au peuple français et
éventuellement sans passer par les
médias pour leur dire ce que vous voulez
écrire la définition
on verra bien vous savez ça c'est de la
cuisine
non c'est maintenant c'est maintenant
vous avez vous avez entendu les siffler
quand vous au Stade de France on va les
montrer dans un instant on les a entendu
le se maintenir au pouvoir alors que
c'est un employé qui est impertinent et
arrogant contre son employeur qui
n'arrête pas de piquer dans le
portefeuille de son employeur parce que
quand on prend l'argent des Français à
travers des mesures qui provoquent
l'inflation alors quand on distribue des
milliards à droite et à gauche sans
demander en permanence vous savez le la
loi du budget elle est passé au 49-3
donc la sentiment du peuple il a ni la
sentiment du peuple ni de l'Assemblée
présidé ça veut dire quoi ce c'est ce
que fait aujourd'hui Hanouna ici il vous
impose pas il vous matraque pas si vous
êtes pas d'accord Macron c'est ce qu'il
fait monsieur j'espère durant le
président
est-ce que tu vas me dire sur Hanouna
s'il vous plaît
est-ce que tu es recherché en ce moment
bah écoutez moi ils savent que j'ai pas
en train de loi donc j'ai pas en train
de loi par contre ils essaient de servir
le matériel en essayant de dire que j'ai
enfin une loi parce que ça sera juste
soumis à l'approbation d'un juge parce
que j'ai fait de la publicité parce que
j'ai pas fait de la publicité donc si il
saisissent le matos il porte un coup
quand même et puis ils veulent me faire
passer pour un délinquant en vrai on va
regarder ce qu'on pense au public
doit-il être sanctionné non à
73%. tu ne dois pas être sanctionné à
64% pour le public c'est votre
26%. je dis merci à tous les Français
merci j'espère qu'il nous regarde tous
merci